[Música]
es el tiempo ya para la economía aquí en
directo a América de edición nocturna
Para ello tenemos preparada ya nuestra
compañera Daniela Blandón Daniela
bienvenida a este espacio Muchas gracias
Rodri Bueno vamos a empezar hablando de
Estados Unidos porque la cámara de
representantes dio la primera aprobación
ya para Elevar el techo de la deuda Así
es pues la ampliación del límite de
endeudamiento que hoy es del 31,4
billones y que es indispensable para que
el país no entre foto en verano quedó
condicionada un recorte drástico del
gasto público esta condición impuesta
por la mayoría republicana en la cámara
ha sido rechazada por el gobierno de Joe
biden se trata O sea por descontado
mejor que en el senado esta ley de tope
de endeudamiento segunda ya que la
mayoría es demócrata el recorte de
gastos que ordena el proyecto es de los
republicanos Y es de 4,5 billones de
dólares y el aumento en el techo de
deuda sería de 1,5 billones de dólares
hemos hecho nuestro trabajo me senté con
el presidente del primero de febrero me
ignoró el resto del tiempo está poniendo
la economía de Estados Unidos en peligro
por su falta de acción ahora debe
sentarse a negociar aprobamos esto
temprano estamos en abril muy por
delante del período límite de la deuda
bueno Dani mientras esto pasa en Estados
Unidos en Bolivia ha sido intervenido
uno de los principales bancos del país
estamos hablando del banco fácil que fue
intervenido en medio de un escándalo por
presunto fraude en el que están
involucrados cuatro de sus ejecutivos
acusados de delitos financieros uno de
los casos que despertó sospecha fue la
aprobación de un crédito equivalente a
uno coma cinco millones de dólares para
una mujer de 18 años que tiene la
capacidad de pago de solamente 10 mil
dólares tras la intervención en clientes
del banco intentaron tomarse algunas
sedes las autoridades anunciaron sin
embargo el beneficio de un proceso de
adjudicación para que otros bancos
asuman los depósitos de los clientes sin
embargo también las operaciones
financieras que dan suspendidas por unos
30 días nos vamos ahora hasta Europa con
una noticia que quizás sorprende porque
se han prohibido las exportaciones de
granos de granos de Ucrania a Rumanía
porque exactamente pues la comisión
europea anunció esta prohibición hasta
el 5 de junio y esto se da a Rodrigo en
momentos en que otros países vecinos
como Polonia Hungría Bulgaria y
Eslovaquia tomaron medidas unilaterales
para prohibir estas importaciones de
productos agrícolas ucranianos Por qué
Porque los agricultores de estas
naciones se sienten en desventaja con
Ucrania por las medidas de protección
impuestas para ayudar a ese país en
guerra
se interseche la comisión ha decidido
que la restricción se aplica a los
siguientes productos ucranianos trigo
maíz semillas de girasol semillas de
colza y aceite de girasol
Julio de sol y ahora volvemos a la
región América Latina Daniela porque hay
muchas noticias así que cuéntanos pues
el primero en Colombia un profesor de
economía de la Universidad Nacional
dirigirá la cartera de Hacienda se trata
de Ricardo Bonilla quien actualmente
dirige la banca de desarrollo
territorial a fin de Tere y ahora
reemplaza a José Antonio Ocampo Quien
salió en medio del revolcón ministerial
anunciado por el presidente Gustavo
Petro el gobierno mexicano discute una
reforma constitucional para recortar de
48 a 40 horas semanales la jornada legal
de trabajo sin embargo la cámara Federal
de diputados aplazó la votación y la
programó para la próxima legislatura en
vista de que ya no hay tiempo suficiente
para avalar la reforma en este periodo
que acaba el 30 de abril
y Argentina comenzará a pagar las
importaciones chinas en yuanes en lugar
de dólares así lo anunció el gobierno
como una medida que apunta a aliviar las
reducidas reservas de dólares de la
nación allí el dólar en el mercado
paralelo está en un nivel nunca antes
visto cercano a los 500 pesos
bueno Daniela ayer hablábamos de comida
en Rusia hoy ya tenemos la barriga llena
Así que vamos a hablar de ropa allá
porque parece que reabren las tiendas de
Zara pues después de que inició la
Guerra en Ucrania recordemos que las
tiendas de Sara fueron uno de los
negocios que cerraron en Rusia en su
caso más de 500 tiendas ahora el Antiguo
local insignia de esta empresa de origen
español en el centro de Moscú abrió pero
bajo la marca maga propiedad de un
conglomerado minorista e inmobiliario
libanés se espera que más de 60 tiendas
abran en los centros comerciales de todo
el país en los próximos días el
Ministerio de industria y comercio de
Rusia dijo que las tiendas de ropa del
grupo inditex que además de Sara es
propietario de Máximo Yuri y otras
cadenas minoristas abrirán con otros
nombres la misma ropa pero diferente
nombre vista parece todo igual Sí señor
bueno Muchas gracias por este repaso
económico nos vemos mañana te invito a
que sigas con nosotros Porque ya llega
directo